I I think it's crazy that you two  suppresses people that they disagree  with or people that tell the truth about  uncomfortable things  um and I'm actually quite nervous that  they might at some point do that to me  so I don't know guys subscribe to my  Rumble um it's usually in the  description of my live shows  um  either Instagram it's  it's tough because you have so many  people that rely  like you know there's I think 13 people  that work at just really things so it's  like those people get out of a job if  they take away the channel  and it's just you know I think Tate was  in a position where it doesn't really  affect him money-wise but it's like  you know they take people's livelihoods  when they do that so it's wrong I don't  know but let me know in the comments  what you guys think